[Music]
Hey hi hello everyone welcome back to
the lobby games last weekly video game
hangout here in San Francisco California
I'm your host Mike McCarty here as
always with reviews editor Peter Brown
hey hi hello how's it going Rob handler
would up and callyblackie hello who's
looking looking Haggard no I'm just
getting tired I'm hipper no I'm just
kidding you you were saying you're tired
from getting raid ready I am very sorry
yeah we've we've all been kind of
getting ready for Destiny's Leviathan
raid that is up right now right yes it's
why people are already doing it but we
start at 1:00 so we can all get food
yeah if you're watching this right now
live yeah like how I said 1:00 p.m.
Pacific we're gonna start doing the six
person raid with people here in the
GameSpot clan are you gonna be partaking
Pete true nope no but I did just hit
level 20 today hey yeah I think I'm
about to 12 I could pull my hat but I'm
not gonna do that my cool destiny app
but I think notebook with things written
it's like I mean there is I feel like
there is now no down time for that game
we're like during a loading screen or
something that you can just be changing
your loadouts like you know just
mantling and stuff like that confusing
you can't dismantle on the app Oh that'd
be awesome
I knew that I played I use the Diablo 3
app a lot back in the day but I oh sorry
to say it but I am level 173 to 273
that's what I meant to 73 I like killing
it I'm like 274 and I have like 2 or 3
engrams to get so I'll probably get
bumped up a little bit yeah Justin hey
Wald yesterday was like yeah raid ready
is 180 I'm like uh I guess I'm ready
ready done after point of like a meeting
at level 18 but nope but he was wrong
yes it's 270 right is that recommended
on the if you go to the director and go
on to the raid it says 270 recommended
but they tweeted I think Lou Smith
tweeted out it's 260 to 280 which means
like you start it starts out being more
two-sixty is with regard to the enemies
and then it scales as you go yeah so
that but I wouldn't recommend going in
at 260 that sounds like a bad time what
do we know about Leviathan raid much at
all or have they said what it's about
I'm going in totally blind I'm sure
people on the internet already know
things about it since streamers are
doing it now but I know that I love sea
monsters and I'm very excited is that
what it is
well Justin saw like a sea monster in
the distance yeah I saw some images on
Titan if you do a story beat it like
appears briefly I didn't see it but if
there's briefly in the background and in
the waves that's pretty sick yes I was
the one times one read on like the
oiling platter like the platforms in the
water yeah Kamino ish cool as always we
have a giveaway I'll get to that later
today now it's at the end of the show
probably gonna go till about noon today
just so you people can fuel up before
the raid yeah like I said Leviathan that
is up weerster me at 1:00 p.m. here at
GameSpot on or not yeah I was gonna
catch you you're not streaming the raid
no we are gonna have vods going up and
like tips for people who want to know
how to do the race so yeah we'll be
updating those as we go through it right
now streaming it we figured we watch the
stream it's a lot of stream but we
figured like if we're gonna have a go at
it because I mean they take hours and
hours right yeah like week six ish
six hours everything like how do you
shoot this boss but that's pretty neat I
don't you have a pretty good team yes
the plan is you know on site you can
check it out for Gamescom and we'll have
like an article that will be continually
updating it so we'll have like the the
videos you can watch us go through it
but cool yeah we will get more to
late-game stuff but I do want to talk
about news stuff ps4 pro still having
problems with destiny it apparently just
crashes every weeks you know every
single day that I play in the office I
get a crash this morning I crashed like
4 times three times in a row was on
necess
when I tried to aim down sights it would
happen real last time yeah it's weird
specifically that I'm not saying that's
the
across the board but for me today that
was the case and it's still happening in
the response is basically like we really
appreciate your patience we're looking
into it that's that's once we finish the
rate it'd be really cool if they could
at least like say okay we've maybe
narrowed it down to this just to show
everyone that like look we are really
pursuing this we are making progress lip
service means nothing yeah yeah cuz I
was I think it was as of yesterday I
looked it up and people are still like
yeah I don't there's no progress really
just ask me I'll tell you it's not
everyone apparently but jean-luc is the
other person I know in our office who
had to bring lower our ps4 home because
he's got one ps4 back carnot you just
couldn't handle it I mean it's a game
breaker you said it like it just hard
crashes and sends you back to the
PlayStation dashboard and you gotta
bring it back and there is nothing worse
than like playing a game being on the
edge you see like is it gonna crash here
is gonna do it oh yeah I know can't you
can't play like that if it's not like it
like the moments I described earlier
like half the time it's been happening
at the end of like a public event or
something okay and I'd like the lützen
site I can see that the crater oh [ __ ] I
am really proud that you got to level 20
and to 12 through all of that well I
know you've been playing it - oh yeah I
played a little bit the office I did
borrow ps4 one day like to get to eight
or something so I got at least that far
mostly it's been at home like yesterday
at home for like five hours
it got me from like 130 up to like I
don't know to 10 or something like that
damn so I put in a lot of time yesterday
Pro Evolution Soccer 18 is out as of
yesterday it is we have a feature up for
mas career dais Oscar - Oscar Davis so
his reviews coming soon are waiting for
the server's to go live so you can
actually like play online and stuff
because that's pretty important he does
have a feature up regarding the sort of
you know what PES is like compared to
FIFA and how it really breaks down to
the idea that well if PES doesn't have
license teams do football fans really
want to play it yeah and it's like well
maybe because the action on the field is
really good but there's always that
thing in the back your mind like this
isn't actually Man United I'm playing
this is yeah Barcelona you know whatever
so greedy beef has been getting like
little bit more clunky ish like
apparently people are saying it's like
by the year it's getting a little more
like harder to control keep learning
yeah I think the consensus is and I'm
speaking as an outsider looking in that
it's trying to assume more realistic
controls but you know that's almost the
difference between a golf game having
the three button press you know
scenario or using the analog sticks
swing and I think it just it comes down
to what you prefer yeah but yeah so
anyway look forward Oscar's review in
the coming days he'll also be reviewing
FIFA so see that Nintendo now finally
that they're extending the limited what
used to be a limited run over the
senesce classic they're extending it
into next year in 2018 so if you don't
get it by December you still have a
chance I mean that's kind of being
reductive cuz I don't know when they're
actually gonna be selling them aren't
they going on sale soon again hopefully
are they all out I don't know I don't
know what about TTS classic man that's
the big news and then that next summer
right in 2018 they're bringing back the
Ness classic that means a lot because
that was the thing that was already
discontinued yeah they're bringing that
back we don't even have the Super
Nintendo yet so I'm ready for them to
change their plans but the NES classic
everyone thought it was gone everyone
was like who knows why Nintendo did this
there's enough
well they've sort of quashed that
question squash it
we've been talking about this a lot
lately between Metroid reviews up we're
gonna get to that between Metroid with
breath a wild with Mario Plus Rabbids
all this third party support that
Nintendo has you got Skyrim coming later
in the year and then like I said Ubisoft
and then partnering for Rabbids yeah
Nintendo also just seems to be listening
to fans I think this Ness classic and
NES classic returning are kind of a good
good indicator of that but also just the
fact that you know we've got a 2d
Metroid back finally with Mercury steam
and Nintendo we've got a lot of stuff
coming back we got you know like a Zelda
game got Metroid Prime for on the
horizon looking forward to we talked
about it last episode but this is just
like further proof of that if you like
that Nintendo's done being weird and
sheltered about a lot of things people
who spent a bunch of money to get like
an NES classic like I would be so mad if
I spend a bunch of money in the NES
classic and they were just getting their
back yeah the people who are spending
that kind of money and those things are
collectors that's true
speaking as someone from that community
I can tell you that it's our own fault
it's that one's fault but our own that
were willing to do that like I bought
the stinky
or whatever 140 bucks for bunch of crap
ish and stuff and the system I don't
feel too bad I'm just really happy to in
tonneaus bring you back oh yeah what's
in the bundle like a carrying case uh no
no I actually so it's like a book that
has like excerpts from the old Nintendo
Power strategy guides Oh for the
Nintendo games that are on the classic
there's a lamp that's like the Mario
question mark block that like lights up
that's fine there's a really basic
puzzle but those of long been sold out
and you should just now buy it for
whatever price you know it's gonna sell
for 60 bucks I think when it comes back
Danny ass classic gonna be 60 yeah it
was snacks will still be 80 bucks yeah
well no power was so cool it was a
wonderful magazine were you the one no
didn't we find a bunch of issues and we
were cleaning out the third floor here
at GameSpot before yes well I've got a
bunch of issues of a few different
magazines it's not necessarily a ton of
power it's like like trying to give
monthly egm to computer gaming something
I don't know there's that some weird
ones I didn't read but they're filled
with interesting stuff like will the
Virtual Boy take over video games yeah I
remember my dad rented the Virtual Boy
yeah from blockbuster that was like
where everyone got exposed to it was
like come on let's check this out set
this thing up on a table looks like a
probe drool I bought one off a dude
Craigslist couple years ago and I've got
one and it's it's cool to have it's
really weird but when I got it it was
almost broken and I was looking at ways
to fix it and you people like dismantle
it and put pieces in the oven to like
because likes it luckily I didn't have
to do that didn't that thing like give
people really bad headaches when back in
the neck that was always what people
said I never met anyone who really I
never met anyone who had a Virtual Boy
before right now I only knew one person
who did same here
I killed him the guy in Craig's mind a
guttural I'm gonna kill this guy first
virtual yeah I had an animal crossing
get an animal crossing no I had you can
get the Virtual Boy oh yeah I just I
noticed your dusty necklace before by
the way people were commenting on it oh
yeah oh cool yeah my mom got it for me
happy
we can whirl the world's right here
sorry your mom got you the Destiny
necklace when team came out yeah okay
that was a cool ad cool have you seen
the Destiny fidgets spinners no it
seemed like it already looks like it is
a Kelly you saw it I did I mean people
are gonna kind of try to see it soon and
Rob you're like never gonna see me I do
not have time this week unfortunately
but uh let's run through it quick I feel
like a lot of people are saying they
liked it I liked it a lot um it's
definitely like a good mix like the book
a good mix of like the coming-of-age
Goonies kind of feel summertime kids in
small town America with the the horror
bits I heard my childhood I didn't
particularly like what they did with the
character of Beverly I feel like she's
like the one girl right Bev I I never
liked anything where there's like the
one girl because as a kid that put a lot
of pressure on me to like embody
everything that the one girl needed to
be in an ensemble and like I just get
irritated with that trope in general but
that wasn't really my problem it was it
was more like in the book you get her
perspective on the romance you get more
of her you know personal perspective on
things and you don't get that as much
and I understand what they have to do
that in a film because they already do a
fantastic job of characterizing this
cast so I can't really fault them for
making that choice but it was very it
was horrifying I liked a lot I had a lot
of fun watching it and also they didn't
include the or he's seen if you're
afraid of that
and they didn't include the scene in the
woods with the police if you know what
that is about the bully stuff was more
terrifying in like the book than it was
I thought boys are so messed up
they're so messed up in this version -
yeah oh gosh oh my god I want to see it
again actually but it was I really liked
it I feel like they struck gold with
like the whole 80s nostalgia thing they
purposely moved the because presumably
the second movie will be the adult
right yes and then in the book and the
91 TV series it was kids were in the 60s
and then when they're adults was the 80s
now they've moved that up so the kids
are their kids in the eighties and I
feel like they're trying to you know
capitalize on the 80s nostalgia of the
stranger
things fad and it sounds like it's
working well it works on me because I
have great nostalgia for a time I wasn't
to life but I loved the eighties a lot
and so I that works really well for me
but there's also this like just
incredible like two seconds scene
featuring New Kids on the Block that
like I I can't explain in words but it's
so it's so good you're like a
masterpiece of a [ __ ] post just in the
movie just in the middle of the movie
isn't like Nightmare on Elm Street 6 on
the marquee over a theater at one point
yes yeah Weapon 4 or 3 or something that
exists Philadelphia cool yeah I wanna go
see that at some point I don't know if
I'll have time this week but like that I
have the book on my shelf still it's
like that what is it
fifteen hundred pages or something it's
crazy yeah have you read The Stand
because that is taking yeah that
miniseries was also kind of good Gary
Sinise
I like that miniseries that was weird
they get it back that gets really weird
too later on like with all the like it's
like Dark Tower ish it's like the real
world but also not really a fantasy dark
fantasy world Stephen King
simultaneously makes me really want to
go to Maine and also never never go to
Maine yeah like what was the freight of
Maine hmm is it storm of the century
I get that perfect storm mixed up which
one is the George Clooney fisherman one
perfect storm storm a century is the one
said Maine where like people come to
grab kids every once in a while kind of
like it he's got a fascination with
kidnapping he he also just loves where
he lives which is Maine yeah means
pretty cool gorgeous that's pretty cool
that come to me also did you see he was
being really salty on Twitter he's like
oh if you guys are waiting for part two
of it just read the book and I was like
thank you yeah he doesn't have a good
history with good directors messing with
his stuff he seemed really really bitter
yeah
and then also last news bit which I
guess LA noire is come to switch they
know since last week kind of like right
after the lobby
ended and we saw that they were gonna
like bring that to the switch rock star
sporting that which they you know like
Rob you said you don't play this much
I'm cool with it yeah I yeah I never
finished it so I'm actually kind of I
might as well I like the game a lot
despite its many frustrations but I'm
imagining with the switch they're gonna
be kind of implementing when you're
doing the detective scenes maybe they'll
be implementing motion stuff
what's the gimme like the elevator pitch
for why this is good
I don't know much yeah it's a weird pick
for me it feel like it's so I mean the
game in general not necessarily why Oh
have you played this got picked no no no
but why is that lame or a game I have no
clue interesting at all I don't know the
game the game was interesting at the
time because of the actual fits I'm
asking well yeah I don't know just like
the actual being able to piece together
information from conversations actually
made you feel kind of like an actual
detective at the time that facial
animation was pretty I remember everyone
was like where you can see behind the
scenes and you're like oh I this it's a
game so this makes sense wouldn't you
wouldn't really do that if you're
actually questioning a real person but
the kind of uncanny valley stuff that
[Laughter]
you watch madmen who see Kenny cosgrove
but to me I was like oh [ __ ] dude from
LA noire and then you know like Dan
Reicher from giant bombs in that game
you can run him over anything this yeah
he's they did a cover trip for the game
at Game Informer that they're like oh we
could put your you into this game he's
this reporter that you can just like
deck if we wanted to yeah but no there
are some frustrations with this game as
far as certain clues not lining up the
way you think they would logically or
vice versa being like how would I put
this together but you kind of figure it
out through the game mechanics not
necessarily how you would logically or
intuitively they're all lying there one
of them I can tell but I don't know why
it's really cool that Nintendo and
Rockstar working together
dude he's an artist look at that sketchy
did oh there yeah they're really good he
is a jack-of-all-trades what your day
job I my remember might like my brother
my little brother it was so into this
game and I was [ __ ] eating grin that was
yeah I'm sorry okay off I just remember
always wanting to play cuz it seems like
the kind of thing I would
really want to play in a time when it
came out so um like but that's not like
a general it's good it's on the sweater
so just I'm happy because I have an
excuse to play it again I guess these
last two people they just show those
sketches were also in Mad Men like the
entire cast of Mad Men is in this game
because they could prove they were a
suit well but I do think it's cool that
they're partnering with a rockstar I
mean it's just we talked about this last
week the having outside support for this
which is so important and that's
something that Nintendo really needs and
that that is cool I don't know this is
if this is a test-case game that's fine
well it's 2013 like the same summer when
Bethesda Ubisoft and EA all said like
we're pretty much not gonna support the
switch or as little as possible from now
on and then you have Ubisoft
is make made Mario Plus Rabbids Rockstar
is doing this Bethesda has Skyrim coming
up I can't think of anything EA related
but I don't know it's just nice yeah 18
coming as well and then yesterday 2k 18
is like full version is December it has
all the features unlike FIFA oh I'll
play Skyrim in a switch i well i plated
it packs and i was just like having a
fantastic time killing stuff again but
like really up close to my face oh and
the amiibo thing I don't think I
mentioned this last week yeah I tried
using the amiibo when I was playing it
and we got footage of it but we got like
a total [ __ ] drop and we didn't get
anything interesting didn't get that
like it was your link outfit it works
the same way it doesn't Selda where you
could get like a really rare item or you
just get like a bunch of food or
whatever so I got like iron boots and
I'm like cool I can go Smith those
myself
well whatever it's been nothing yeah
what other like I guess start with last
gen games because la noir was wide like
a few years into the 360 ps3 lifecycle
do you have any other games Kali that
you would like to see from that era come
to the switch um I mean I think I'm a
little bit of a weird case cuz that was
a time period where I'm still catching
up on some of those games I was really
focused on school at that time so I mean
like look how that worked out but like I
there's a lot of games I would love to
have an excuse to to revisit and like
games I want to catch up on so
I can't think of one off the top of my
head I mean that is one that I I really
wanted to play I haven't played Red Dead
I would love to have Red Dead yeah
that was another one that like everybody
and my [ __ ] school was talking about
excuse me especially getting ready for
playing a lot of destiny and swearing a
lot
what about like do you play the Arkham
games no I tried them don't like them
really not for me
you play the article honden I didn't
really dive into that stable the Arkham
sorry I think would be great I think the
first thing that kind of sparked that
idea was the the actual scanning the
environments and detective stuff it's
very vanilla but compared to LA noire or
something like that but I think those
games work well they were they were
good-looking in terms of like their
stylistic direction but they weren't
like I don't think they be exceptionally
tasking on the switch it's all taxing
sorry I say tasking I'm tired to tell
about scaling that stuff yeah I think
those work out well I like the first two
might the first ones my favorite Arkham
Asylum I think that's a really good like
3d action Metroidvania ish game did you
play the 3ds Arkham game that actually
was trying to be a Metroidvania no it
did this really annoying thing here you
had a 2d map that looks like any other
map yeah like in a Metroidvania but the
game would let you go in the Z direction
like so there are rooms that were behind
other rooms but it wouldn't be reflected
on the map and so you would not actually
the map was kind of useless yeah it
would give you like half of the info you
needed and that was all you could get
out of his discussing there's a really
frustrating game it was kind of
interesting but I didn't play the first
room there's Wii U games I'd love to see
on switch oh yeah we have two toad it's
so precious never play that isn't it
can't you not jump isn't that one of its
legs right he just he waddles around I
love him so much
it's a great little game I think
everyone's been asking for that one you
know I think project tracker on switch
as well because it's all these little
bite-sized challenges yes I wanted
mission dead space you had that on why
changed it on the run show - dad space I
changed I know that wasn't purpose I
changed all Vance's dead
he teams everything I run a show art ham
trilogy dad space booka booka me miss
effect yeah dead space
my favorite stop eating that part my
favorite game come out of last
generation for sure yeah I like super
impressive start for that IP I mean
before it even came out I think everyone
kind of knew like oh [ __ ] like this is
sci-fi or that we've never seen before
yeah it left a pretty good impression on
me at least the first two did I didn't
quite like the third necessarily but
that series is gone effectively like
where it where dat yeah to get a chance
to play that again it was amazing the EA
in the first place was like gave Visser
all the green light because they were
because when it was something totally
different and then when resin Evil 4
released they like revamped a bunch of
the stuff their own project yeah Matt
Padgett he's a freelance for us he wrote
something on I think PC gamer about it I
forget what it was that would be really
good you and then I wrote Okami terms of
Wiggy and I think would be really good
to come over
kinda like Zelda ish but also really
stylistic well they announced that the
remaster yeah really doesn't include
switch on it yeah that's weird
what is it coming to what we you what no
peace for Xbox one they just announced a
general Okami HD yeah Oh gotcha okay I
would be surprised if that doesn't come
to switch eventually yeah yeah I'd be
surprising especially considered the
well I guess platinum isn't really like
Platinum's made up of X clover people
who made Okami but they don't have they
don't know know what those rights it's
all kind of home
what about Mass Effect yeah
I would absolutely play Mass in dromeda
no sorry look I hate kicking that game
actually yeah oh yeah we're not gonna
make anything else for this game
yeah oh my god I didn't I missed that
they do an anthem they're doing
something new in the Dragon Age
franchise Mike Laidlaw the creative
director they were hiring people a while
ago and he said yeah we're doing
something new but we're not announcing
what it is hopefully it makes up for
Inquisition a game that I had some fun
with but then it stopped caring about it
for like ten hours any other games from
last gen we wanna see Metal Gear Rising
revengeance
that'd be good yeah the what's the
elevator pitch for that for people who
might not know that Platinum yeah
aberration it's a it's a sort of hyper
very demanding action like you know
third-person combat game where you play
a cybernetic ninja in the future the
character the nominee people love from
Metal Gear but one that actually gets I
think his best chance to shine yet this
is way after it is the last name in the
timeline Oh gotcha yes this is like when
the yeah it's it's the whole military
corporation ruling the world and all
these different mercenary factions PMC's
yeah it's uh it's a really interesting
game it was one of those things that
Kojima was making internally but not
really running the project he was having
his younger staff do it the game was not
heard of for a while and then commie
basically said sorry our younger
employees don't know what they're doing
and we're gonna pull this game and then
I think it was just a few days later
some short order after that platinum was
like don't worry we got this
so Kojima worked with platinum producers
and we ended up with this great game is
really good I mean it's bait you know if
you like Platinum's action like from
bayonetta this is a sort of interesting
translation of that into the miller-urey
universe and it's got some really cool
fights like this whole system of
chopping enemies apart and how well that
works is surprising and I'm and I wish I
could have seen that in another game but
yeah like that when you saw him sort of
tear the spine out of that dude and
crush it like that's how you regain
health from enemies you beat and it is
such a that's so cool I never use this
word such a visceral experience I mean
you're playing with robotic viscera and
you feel that like impact so I think I
can use it I think you can that is I
give you a pass for this I don't this
was also recently added to Xbox one
backwards compatibility oh that's great
news yeah I think this is also one of
those games that was like ported to the
Nvidia shield of all things which is
essentially the hardware that the switch
runs on and see pretty much the same
chipset just a more efficient version of
it so this game can get tough I'm not
playing theory I was really hard at some
points yes especially when you replay as
Sam who's like the main villain of the
game you can go through it again and
it's really tough with him looking at
hell-blade recently and like heavenly
sword and whatnot ninja theory I'd love
to see Devil May Cry coming aren't they
working
yeah I loved the reboot I didn't like
what this name
Dante yeah a new Dante no is that so his
name in the new one yeah reboot yeah
Devil May Cry DMC or whatever it's
called or vice to Democrat that makes
way more sense I really like that game
and I would like to see that on switch
any like current gen well a lot of
people are mentioning the 3d Zelda's or
any like I yeah I would absolutely
Oh God replay like Majora's Mask 3d and
what oh I'm just i they were 100 percent
bring majora and ocarina I need Twilight
in winwaker though I was already
I mean link especially for Wind Waker in
Majora's Mask in particular those HD or
I guess those remake remasters improved
some things that weren't great that
didn't work as well like the bosses are
better in Majora's Mask 3d and then you
have the Swift sail and Wind Waker HD so
I would love to play those again and
then ocarina and Majora's Mask both like
remap certain equipment items to the
item screen so you have to keep pausing
everything and there were a little small
visual tweaks soccer as well yes and
Majora's Mask as I know I'd get
hyperbolic about Zelda games but
Majora's Mask is if people asked my
favorite game and the 3d version the 3ds
version they actually changed it so you
could skip to certain times on the
timeline rather than only like this day
ahead or and every time you can save the
game without having to go back to the
beginning of the first day a lot of big
systemic yeah overhauls yeah oh I love
that games so much I like right there
with you it's my favorite zelda tear
down Skyward Sword I'd be interested to
see if they could bring that to switch
without the motion controls Skyward
Sword and takes like all take fee out
peace
he's a cool character at first but then
she just starts telling you how to solve
puzzles I haven't played it because I
hate the art style but I would give it a
chance for this on switch you don't like
it
hate the art style Wow my caption I hate
it it's like like things that the draw
distance doesn't pick up or whatever it
like watercolor that's a good
description hate how link looks I want
to punch his dumb face I hate it I love
the flying
I love link I love him so much and I
hate how it
looking skyward sorry today I really
like the flying on the loft wings and
links got the red one everybody else has
a purple one that game that game is not
fantastic in my opinion but screw the
intro to that game it's like two hours
of who you were playing video game
before yeah the rest of that game kind
of does that too though with feet she's
like all but the intro is especially bad
I don't remember it that much my
princess is really long
mm-hmm yeah but no this is like tutorial
izing controls I'm not talking about in
trowing the stick will move your
character wait I mean yeah or less you
mentioned like winwaker toilet princess
which are on the Wii U and I played
through winwaker for like the third time
ever weirdly enough because i played all
those a lot but me and jake decker he
had never played twilight princess so we
started playing through it on the wii u
but if i had both those games notes
which i would happily play through them
again and nintendo has a couple years
ago like they made a big deal about oh
we've got this new way to port games
across platforms put it to use see it go
for it do it I mean they've they've kind
of done it with Mario Kart and Pokemon
but pokken tournament mmm what was the
other one game Mario karts man no no not
yet I wish man it smashing easy to make
either way are you party no I'm kidding
the yeah the idea of having Twilight
Princess or yeah winwaker on there as
well as those ocarina Majora's Mask
remasters will be awesome hmm and then
also getting all their online stuff
they're not the eShop the getting old
what is it called the ability to
download old Nintendo games what is it
called
we're to a console virtual console thank
you why did you leave me hanging
that would be great to have all those
two DS Elda's on the switch tablet yeah
I don't think we're gonna see Virtual
Console the way that we saw it before as
like a category we're like a service
that's like the individual games I think
the antennas gonna try to sell these
things as like little bundles of old
games held by them and they're gonna do
their subscription service obviously
which a man they've mentioned but I yeah
I don't think we're didn't see a virtual
console the way we knew it any other
games franchises you'd like to see on
swish I'd like to see some Star Wars
make it some rogue squadron maybe mmm
like old school like GameCube rogue
squadron was a game to ups
I actually never got into the games
queue Brooks Potter by heard good things
they were good
yeah there were two of them even like I
can I took Old Republic I was about to
say that because that game looks like
ass now and I can't play it anymore and
I loved that game and if they just made
it look a little better I play the [ __ ]
out of it I think was a year ago and
they like had an update it was like it's
now in 4k and it's like okay on the
YouTube chat side Metroid Prime trilogy
oh that's a good yeah I would not be
surprised to see with four kind of
coming whenever Metroid Prime I love I
love those games especially the first
and corruption the third one echoes is
kind of punishing with it's like shadows
like you can't go into the shadows or
you have to like recharge in the
sunlight or whatever it is but I like
this games a lot the first one is an
all-time classic yeah every time I watch
footage of that game I just feel like I
need to play this again right now it's
just it's kind of reminds me of what I
don't know Nintendo did with Ocarina
like take this traditional franchise and
implement 3d aspects to it but in a way
that just makes it go unreal I really
like Metroid Prime and I want to play
that again and hearing the music of
Samus Returns like makes me nostalgia
for that hype entire franchise also I'm
just kind of realizing it I mean
obviously Red Dead but why not like a
grand theft auto that's yeah Grand Theft
Auto five I think could be easy it's on
ps3 and 360 which are less powerful than
a switch so I mean it easily it's not
yeah not five for you know like [ __ ]
man the league before yeah before is
kind of unlikely that game had like a
lot of weird ports that like didn't work
very well I think that codebase is
[ __ ] and they're probably oh I'm also
happy that Nintendo is like loosening up
on life like adultishbooks and boobies
and violence I like that you know we've
noted before that the commercials are
geared towards adults and so like
clearly they're not trying to be like oh
that's too that you can kill a
prostitute don't
so yeah what about like bully that's
been re-released on a few different
platforms that's right it's backwards
compatible in xbox yeah mm-hmm police
fight City
Beleza ooh I got a good one thrashing
Clank that'd be awesome if Sony just
throwing out there now they'll be really
they're slowly rolling in these games
now you have enough what about maybe
that impossible though yeah about like a
halo like someone mentioned or e2 and
being like yeah all right I see him all
at table playing cards like ran out of
money so he bet there's a reason he bet
the halo franchise when his friend went
all-in oh my god yeah that would be that
would be great Rob destiny - we've been
playing a lot more of it mm-hmm
we're kind of getting to post game stuff
doing some milestones every week they
reset every week milestones year are
part of the weekly reset and then
there's a daily challenge reset that's
like on each planet has its own set of
three challenges and you get like planet
tokens which you can redeem for with
that choruses know you can read I think
you just get them automatically but like
you get if you complete the necessary
example you get neces tokens and you go
to failsafe and she gives you gear for
the most part I feel like they're always
in the loot chests right those tokens
not necess Quinn's yeah the tokens
tokens the tokens are often in loot
chests or as a drop from like a
high-level enemy but yeah but anyway
yeah like we're doing the postgame stuff
a lot of us except Peter who hasn't
finished the story no but I'm 20 so yeah
I want to avoid story missions as much
as possible yes it's it's a mix of many
factors I heard you talking talking
about it and I was trying to avoid the
conversation because I was like I don't
want to I have to write about these
later opinion but I mean that's the
thing is like the story missions are
sort of like you get through them yeah
and then you go on to like the actual
game I don't know how great that is as a
design I feel like a lot of games employ
that I for me the story missions provide
just enough context to make me feel like
okay what I'm doing actually makes sense
which I didn't have in the first game
where it was almost like I had to have
other people tell me what we were doing
and why
whereas this game I feel much more like
oh it's it's kind of laid out a little
bit a lot better for me sure so I don't
need it to be like brilliant and the
story super basic and the enemy is you
know like a very typical villain and
it's you know it's a very basic thing
but there's like a warthog run style
level when there's there's cool stuff
they mix it up yeah like that sounds
good it's it's the it's the other
missions where it feels like okay you're
setting out with like a goal in mind
say you got a restore power to this
thing okay so to do that you gotta do
this one thing so you go there you
complete that task damn it didn't work
like you thought it had to so now you
gonna have to go do something else and
turns out all you don't do just one of
those you gotta do like four of them and
yeah it just it feels I think I forget
who I was talking to yesterday I think
it was you like every mission always
needs a plan like B and C and D because
it's never just a simple proposition and
then you take care of it and so that
gets a little tiring for me yeah because
I feel like the game like III never
trust what the game is telling me I
never trust that like what I'm doing is
actually going to achieve the goal that
everyone wants it to yeah it kind of
sucks
and then Ramazan you this morning about
the idea that one of the missions wants
you to be level 15 and it's like well
that's an easy way to Pat out the story
is to put a level cap on a mission that
how does that make any sense in the
context of you know our version of
playing the game right like within the
world
self why do levels have any bearing on
anybody that's nothing anyway yeah you
could argue it is forcing you to play
the side stuff explore like like because
I was you know like you inclined to like
I want to knock out the story right like
any kind of game you know even halo
right I got a beat the campaign before I
dive into anything else yeah but here
it's I mean you know that's a core part
of the game is exploring and doing side
quests so maybe that's a by means of
reassuring themselves that like you'll
you'll have that idea that that's
something that you need to do I mean
simply to me it's a it's a cheap way of
making the game seem more making your
stories seem more interesting than it is
like not even more interesting but like
it distracts you from realizing how
simple and straightforward it is because
it distracts you and tells you to go do
something else rather than letting you
actually like if you went through those
missions one by one which I was taking
breaks to go do adventures to go do
public events if I was to go through the
missions one by one I would I would be
even more mad about the story as it is
so like I I don't I don't see the
excuses that that being a good thing
that they make you go out that doesn't
help the story be any better cuz I can
already do that stuff if I want to like
the story should make me want to keep
going through it for the sake of itself
I always thought those level
requirements were just because the
difficulty would be too high for some
they scale everything else in the game
yeah why wouldn't they scale those
missions if they can if they can scale
outside of that I don't see why they
can't do it there and that's just that's
just covering up the fact that there's
not an interesting story to tell
by making it about the difficulty rather
than actually like yeah what you're
doing especially if they're like
single-player you know like they're
they're separate from like the open
world right yeah favorite subclasses or
anything yeah like Cara Lee how many of
you played for your hunter I played all
of them and lately I've been really
liking the new subclass Orchestrator I
really like it I used to pretty much
exclusive of unite stalker which is the
one with the bow and arrow and the void
but Ark trader has been helping me get
through like waves of enemies and it
helped a lot for last week's nightfall
so I've been doing that and also all of
my gear is is a for Ark so
it works out that way but uh there it is
wow that was really fast buffing your
art damage being surrounded with that
engaged is so fun just to go back and
forth like enacting it it feels really
fluid like the arc Strider I really do
dig it it does like yeah that's
Nightstalker but really really quickly
going back to the the story stuff I that
I do really like Destiny's Laura I know
a lot of people think it can be pretty
stupid but there's I think there's like
there's cool stuff there there's
interesting things between the different
races like I really find the VEX are
very interesting and I do like that the
story gives more context to those things
as well but like that's the thing is
like you finish the story and then you
have a hundred more hours plus of things
you can do and it's really just like a
way to set up okay here's here's why
you're doing the rest of the actual cool
stuff
and I I agreed that that's like not a
great way to get you to keep playing and
that is frustrating and I don't think
it's particularly like well-written or
anything but also I think it serves its
purpose so I'm kind of I'm oh we have a
weird mind about it and it's really
difficult to evaluate on that because
I'm like well that's not why I play
destiny right yeah but also like I can't
just give them a pass for having like
that level cap thing that's kind of lazy
you know what I mean
have you been like getting like exotic
weapons I saw you got racking the other
night I did oh that was awesome that was
so cool that's the thing is like that
was I mean I did they've called destiny
won a platform and they meant like a
platform to add more content to but for
me it's also a platform to to do the
things that you want to do and make it
your own and so for for Rat King
I don't even plan to use that weapon so
if you don't know rat Kings like a
sidearm its stacks the more people in
your fireteam have it so it gets more
powerful if everybody has it and you
have to complete a nightfall with five
minutes remaining which is pretty
challenging and it took so many tries I
mean we were doing it for like two hours
and we finally got it it was like I
don't even want to use this weapon but I
did it and I had such a good time work
together with my team and like figuring
out the best way to do this and it was
really rewarding it's like I'm never
gonna actually really use that weapon
it's not good for PvP like I don't need
it but it the the process of getting it
was so awesome it stacks when people
have it equipped or yeah so like if you
and I went into a fireteam we would have
two times power and I think increased
reload speed or something like that is
that when weapons were using it with the
secondary it reloads when you get kills
which apparently is the name of a
Finnish metal band Sturm drank Sturm and
Drang or I don't know if that's true I
thought it was like a durmstrang
reference from Cotter
[Laughter]
what's the other one boom baton boom
yeah rainbow baton Hogwarts hope it's
you try wizard tournament I went there
she's a Vela yeah is that like it means
well she's half below it and velar like
basically sirens anyway any other like
your review will be up in the coming
days at some point you're doing the raid
today so yeah obviously you didn't want
to have a final thought on it yet doing
the raid today thing cramming for Friday
for the final review I do have a daily
review diary that I closed out going
into the raid if you want to check out
my impressions thus far and it's a good
example of just sort of a more personal
take on your experience as well the
interviews can be little bit formal but
you've been able to sort of inject more
of a alright done dirty business who's
the real deal yeah yeah it's nice guys
like I really enjoy destiny and I
acknowledge that there's things that I
think are like technically wrong with it
it's a very tricky game to review and
I've always struggled with this with
destiny but it was cool to do like a
daily like here's what I did and it was
really freaking cool it was really
frustrating or whatever whatever it is
accidentally mantled all of my shards or
something like that right
i dismantle it excuse me mantle you can
mantle shards you can mantle in the same
now I I got crushed by a cabal lander
like I was stealing it
[ __ ] fell on me did the nightfall
streamed it Eric Tay and I and Aaron and
that happened to Tay like twice in a row
we like wiped and started again and I'm
just chasing today trying to keep up
with him yeah sure enough cabal
transport Sam yeah happened twice in a
row and I happened me once it's not cool
it's it's hilarious and I definitely
always the PlayStation can you please
right here so this is Dana yesterday
this was my first attempt at the or we
end up doing it in the end it was pretty
in I think we was like how many times
did we do it today it was like six times
we had to wipe and a couple of them were
actually due to bugs which was
unfortunate like a waypoint never like
got engaged
so we just yeah that happened once Aaron
was on in the other room playing and he
said like the platform he was on like
just disappeared and he couldn't spawn
and then yeah enough if you know about
the knife also you're like trying to
like beat the time the strike eleven
minutes the clock and there's certain
things you can do to increase the time
you have four so for this nightfall it
was to jump through those rings that you
saw oh so that changes changes so for
last week's it was killing enemies at a
time I got it um I but it's it's
challenging and it's it's just really
fun to do with like the right group of
people Oh totally I had a I had a fun
time with it like the and the main
challenge is that you you know you have
the three types of elements associated
with your class powers as well as you
know weapons and and orchestrating with
your team basically like it it shifts
around so if it's on arc or double
damage and everything else does half so
you want to use the correct element so
it's fun to like switch around and you
know you want ideally you want all your
subclasses to be different so that
everyone can use their super or like the
boss at the right time
yeah so I played with Ben djenka and
John Luke and we were just being like
okay well before we go in who has a void
energy who has the ark who has the solar
and we like coordinated at all so
everybody had access to everything at
any time and we were calling it out like
we were like like it was really intense
eric was exhausted that day we were we
were calling it out like alright it's
void I'm going in like and it got really
intense and it was just it's it's a lot
of fun and that's that's the stuff that
that you're working towards and destiny
and those are the super rewarding things
and I never really had that with one for
a multitude of reasons so I'm really
enjoying that this time around for sure
overall you I think it's a general
consensus that they have improved a lot
since even like taking King and rise of
iron was not much at all that was kind
of an incremental thing after taking
Kings yeah big expansion but overall it
seems like they've improved a lot yeah
it's a big improvement on destiny one
eye I'm not I don't think that if you
didn't like the basic fundamentals of
destiny one that you would be like
converted by destiny to necessarily it's
very similar in formula but there's
small enough changes throughout that
make it a much better experience um if
that makes that makes any sense like I
wouldn't say like oh this is so so big
of an improvement that's gonna convert
people who didn't even like the
fundamentals of destiny one I wouldn't
go for so far as to say that but it is
such a good and good improvement on so
many different levels of the game that
yeah I'm really enjoying it and I wasn't
saying what is I can't remember what's
the Warlocks third arc ability or what's
that subclass called stormcaller
yes that's been my favorites but like
when you engage it you kind of hover and
I think the character design is cool the
design if you look at the character I
feel like his his or her back is like
cricket like the spine is just curved
and you just going around like
but it's fun so like you like can chain
yeah electricity through all these
element to wipeout like just a herd of
thrall is just gratifying like I got
this that's the shield ones pretty boy
it's like catherine america mixed with
Wonder Woman but also also Athena from
Borderlands the pre-sequel at a very
similar class she was a very similar
class I doubt I don't know how much they
took from that but what class are you
Peter so I've got a warlock it's 20 I've
got a hunter that's 8 or 9 I kind of
want to start a Titan because I didn't
play destiny 1 is my first time really
getting into the series so I feel like I
want to get all the classes under my
belt and there's some eccentricities
about the warlock that I'm not in love
with but jumping is so weird jumping is
weird
I kind of like it I don't know I'm also
I get weird about like what my character
looks like for some reason I'm very much
into like identifying with like cool
looking gear and like the hunter having
the hood I'm like okay there's no like
cool silhouette for the head so I don't
like the way they look but also the
warlock has like you know lots of like
drapey things going on and like there's
no way to like not have that yeah it's
like okay I feel like I'm stuck into
that and that's fine it's not as bad as
the hunter the Titan seems to get
interesting mixed then I see like really
weird typefaces see that the weirdest
Titans that are like this why's your
been changes like a sick Titan II is
like weird glowing glowing orange
shoulder I've seen like more variety
among that class than any other one so I
feel like that coupled with its sort of
Wharton you know more tank ish like
elements that might be a nice change of
pace whether or not I stick with that
long term I don't know but I'm curious
to sort of keep myself engaged with the
game if doing that will help me feel
like rejuvenated again I just got 220 so
I'm still I'm like I haven't gotten an
exotic yet I mean I you know just open
my first or engrams and stuff today and
it's like I'm still new to all of that
yeah I've still got a long ways to go
before I've really experienced destiny I
feel like yeah I'm Titans part as well
Titans have been frustrating I mean I
definitely start a titan class but like
in PvP thank you to really like Titan oh
yeah I played when I played the small
amount of destiny one I was definitely
rocking tighten yeah it's got a lot of
cool moves I think they'll like trends
transition really well into PvP like I
swear there's so many times where I'm
like holding a point and some objective
based mode and I see you tighten like a
mile away I know what he's gonna do and
he just come sprinting in does that
shoulder check I'm trying to like shield
that yeah I'm just as a warlock
linebacker oh yeah maybe I suck that's
very much likely the case but also I
feel like at a disadvantage compared to
hunters who have that melee and Titans
who have the shield what's the what's
the Warlock class subclass void no
that's hunter voidwalker that's the bow
and arrow Night Stalker
what's voidwalker that's the bow staff I
think there's a storm collar for warlock
is a void collar for forelock that's
that's like it apparently in the meta
for the game right now that's the most
powerful subclass oh really a damage
that does Jake and I've been calling
Night Stalker nightcrawlers I was like
you crawl crawl head Walker worms in the
night Boyd Boyd walking I don't play
well I'm like anti warlock over here I
really can not like I'm not like anti
other people being more like but I like
refused to make a warlock I I probably
will eventually because I've been been
really like trying to like make a new
character which I haven't done yet cuz
I've been focused on the review but like
dawn blades pretty sweet you have that
like ability to shoot fire out of it
right yeah but like you have that the
series of abilities were like you can
it's basically like like hi like you
miss to play like the lifts and glide
but you can continually fire while
gliding which is pretty sweet to do that
like around an enemy or something like
that like always be mobile instead so
it's cool anyway destiny to your full
review will be up in the coming days but
you can go read like your daily review
Diaries in a review in progress
we'll have more on the raid later today
once you guys all start it from one
probably until the end of the work day I
would imagine teh leaves at 7:00 yes and
I do want to get to metroid because now
a Pete your review is fully up a lot of
people looking around
other reviews I'll agree this is kind of
what a lot of people have been asking
for for a long time the return of 2d
Metroid in the time when Metroidvania
has come out all the time now there's
been some great ones this year there's
holo night there's dead cells you early
access game if you want to look back a
few years or in the blind forest there's
axiom verge which is very much a classic
one and coming to switch and come to
switch that one that's another game that
seems tailor-made for that makes sense
but I want to talk about Metroid Samus
returns the reimagining of Metroid to
return of Samus yeah we talked a bunch
about it last week I don't really
remember everything we touched on but
the rumors are true the game is great
you I would say superb in fact I did
it's so what we have is I'll just sort
of run down the basics again it's a
reimagining of Metroid to essentially
Samus is sent to sr388 to get rid of
Metroid's because they're a threat
because if the space pirates get them
they're gonna use in and take over the
galaxy mm-hmm
so you get down there you try to do that
and you're basically trying to hunt down
the last remaining Metroid's and if you
know this game has been out for a while
and even if you played Super Metroid you
know what happens at the end of this
game Samus does a thing which defies
good judgment idiot yeah and kind of
goes against her mission which is you
know it makes this game a really pivotal
part in the series it's sort of is the
dividing line between you know Metroid
Prime and Metroid and then Super Metroid
and he's in and all the stuff after that
maybe I'm screwing up that timeline I
hope not
the so the great thing though like you
know it's got a brand new map which does
change the flow of the game quite a bit
but it's also allowed them to adopt a
similar exploration that you'd find in
Super Metroid or fusion or zero mission
which is you get this map you have lots
of doors that are blocked off by certain
weapons and you you know you go you make
progress throughout the map at large
based on the equipment you have and use
that to access new areas as you get it
now in the past coupled with that was
the idea that you were hunting for
hidden items in your environment and it
would take a lot of trial and error to
kind of find those things but this game
you now have a scam possibility which
will essentially allow you to analyze
your environment and pinpoint where
these items are hey you're saying that
sounds like it robs we have the
experience of the
cover e and stuff well it robs you maybe
others experience of discovery but
actually getting the items is more
difficult because you have to perform on
a more regular basis sort of complex
puzzles that will then net you the items
that you locate I really like it it
makes it less like G's randomly shooting
at different parts of the wall and doing
power bombs here and there we're smart
or not know where it is it's more like a
treasure hunt how do I get to it like
how do I get that X and it's yeah it has
made me like the backtracking and
exploration more than I thought I would
yeah and it has teleportation
teleporters that's a first for the
series as far as I'm aware and that
helps quite a bit
the other influences we got is from
Mercury steam the company who made this
with Nintendo did a lot of the
development they made this a more
action-oriented game and that kind of
works to the game's favor because like
the you know changed up to exploring
environments changing up combat is
something that the series has kind of
always needed it's it's it used to be
like a like a slower sort of combat
experience we're like enemies wouldn't
necessarily charge at you all the time
they'd be nearby maybe they'd drop from
a ceiling at you but in this game most
of them charge at you the moment they
see you and you have to learn how to
parry and stop them which is strange at
first but once you get a hang of it
Samus feels way more like physical and
powerful than she ever really has before
it's not just her gun doing the work
it's her like hitting away these enemies
you know it's her kind of dealing that
that damage I was watching some of our
footage and I was watching John Luke's
footage ah he's doing a history of 2d
Metroid video I think at some point
maybe later this week or don't quote me
on that this move that you guys just saw
that's related to the one thing I don't
like about this game um I'll get a
second this it seems to me like watching
Super Metroid footage and watching on
YouTube I haven't played it in a long
time I know you recently played it do
you feel like there are mmm or enemies
in this like per room I feel like Super
Metroid there were there was a decent
amount of them but I feel like I'd ran
into him far like not as frequently I
will say this game uses it doesn't have
as broad of a range of enemies as the
other games but it definitely mixes and
matches them on a more regular basis and
in
or in in ways that grow increasingly
difficult to contend with a lot of times
in Super Metroid yeah I'd be like maybe
one type of enemy per room maybe two but
they'd be easily avoided so it
definitely feels like there's more in
this I think because they rush at you
because you can't just ignore them yeah
but but also yes I think they you know
they lack variety in enemy design but
they certainly use the enemies in more
interesting ways
yeah in larger numbers the one thing you
don't like you mentioned it kind of
defies logic yeah you kind of just saw
it but yeah so basically every item you
get in this game it's described you know
in your inventory like okay here's what
you can do with it and when you get a
new gun or something it's okay you can
open these doors with it so you know you
you have all that you have the ability
to locate everything in your environment
so you're given like a lot of info and
you're forced to use that info in clever
ways which is one of the great things
about the game but when you're nearing
100 percent and you realize oh yeah
there's some items hidden behind these
paths that are just covered in red
crystals that there's no physical way to
like touch and get by them you have to
literally avoid them well how do you do
that well you're not you're not gonna
figure it out by reading the
descriptions in your inventory you're
not gonna find it out by reading the
manual essentially the the way the way
that you do it is the only thing in the
game that is not described to you and it
actually it uses a behavior
inconsistently so if you drop a regular
bomb when you're in a morph ball samus's
ball will pop up right if you lay a
superpower bomb she will not pop up when
in morph ball mode except if you're
using her spider ball which allows her
to attach to a wall or a ceiling defying
gravity then the powerbomb will send her
flying which is opposite logic you would
think if you weren't tethered to
something the bomb would send you flying
it doesn't send you anywhere period
that's what makes people worse is that
it's that when you try it you think oh
the power bomb will never send me
anywhere yeah if it was ever going to it
would here no you have to hold on to the
wall and let it do it yeah and again you
have to figure that out on your own and
I had to actually like work with people
who are also playing a game to figure it
out but I yeah it's kind of bothered me
for days and it made me really kind of
frustrated because everything else by
this game is really really good I
mentioned to you the only way I can see
that being a thing it's like oh you've
got this on
like on movable things stuck to the wall
and then you have this unstoppable bomb
it's like crossing the streams so to say
I guess but if you see but if you see
the regular bomb do it why wouldn't the
power bomb do it yeah without without
using that spider ball yeah I mean
there's no work there's no two ways
about it like that's that's inconsistent
it's too bad
working though where's his fall do you
think on the list of Metroid games no
that's very difficult
I haven't played fusion or zero mission
a long time I so I was helping jean-luc
by pretty much giving him like all my
Metroid stuff for a shoot and I played a
minute of zero mission I was like damn I
don't remember this game being because
it was like the save at the end of the
game I was it kind of member beans
powerful in this game like this is kind
of cool but I will say that it's
certainly not one that I would put
towards the bottom yeah the fact that I
have to consider you know like it's it's
better than Super Metroid in some ways I
think personally speaking I prefer super
metroids horror elements I think that
that works better with the isolation and
the fact that looked a series of modeled
after alien that feels like an alien
game more than something like this but
I'm okay with that
the soundtrack in Super Metroid
definitely lends itself more to that
like horror mystery then I would say
Samus returns though yeah yeah I mean I
bring this up often but the title screen
alone has bleeding corpses on it in
Super Metroid but that's kind of that's
that Super Bowl that's a really bold way
to sort of set the scene I think they've
I think this is an excellent example of
what they should continue to do with the
series alongside whatever they do with
Prime I have hopes this will come out on
switch because it was made on them on
the mercury engine which was used to
port mirror fate HD another mercury
steam game from 3ds to other platforms
like PlayStation and Xbox so there's you
know there's potential there of course
then tendo's tools that I talked about
earlier you're optimistic rust about
seeing more 2d very optimistic about
seeing more 2d metroids Yoshio Sakamoto
the producer at Nintendo who worked with
Mercury steam said an interview with
Game Informer they pitched a remake of
fusion we said no remake this sorry I
don't to cut you off Fusion is the
Gameboy advanced game yes okay getting
him straight my doors because I like
that game a lot but I've always forget
which one was on the GBA if I remember
correctly Fusion is the last one in the
timeline so
Mercury's team wants to remake that
and Sakamoto also said if this set if
this sells we want to make more 2d
metroids I mean he made it pretty clear
like it's not like this is just a
one-off for the 3ds owners they're like
no we're trying to start some things and
it's not surprising they try it on 3ds
first just low development cost compared
to something like switch that makes
sense I'm glad they partnered with
mercury steam because I I played a
mirror of fate knowing the game they
also did lords of shadow 1 and 2 yeah
and Murphy was alright but it wasn't
anything spectacular compared to Metroid
Samus returned especially sure best
story in the Castlevania series I think
but I don't remember it last you bet but
it has a lot to do with like who is
Dracula yeah like that yeah I really
yeah it's I was mentioning earlier you
have like Halloween you have dead cells
you have axiom verge in recent years you
so many these games are coming out
trying to game design can be cyclical so
like Metro failures are kind of coming
back into fashion now and I'm glad to
see like Nintendo coming out and proving
oh we can still do it too Nintendo like
partnering with Mercury steam but still
a lot of Nintendo is on this project
definitely and I'm optimistic about that
are you guys gonna play this hell yeah I
mean I don't have a 3d yes but it's been
it's been tough to get any kind of play
with everyone's everyone's like there's
like queue straight up for like this
game but yeah it sounds awesome
excuse me awesome it is fantastic I like
it a lot yeah I don't have a lot of
experience with Metroidvania so I'm a
little nervous about that like I feel
like I might be more easily frustrated
because I just the my vocabulary with
those kinds of games is pretty limited I
think but I still want to check it out I
think but I don't know if like should I
start with a different like I haven't
played Super Metroid like I I feel like
I should play Super Metroid I feel like
this is the most accessible yeah I was I
would as an intro to the series I would
say this is that's true yeah or Metroid
it's and it's also the direct prequel so
the events lead right into Super Metroid
really pretty much yeah huh Super
Metroid on switch would be dope I would
how I wish it's on this
that's classic uh though right isn't it
Super Metroid yep yeah sweet oh yeah
that'll be good get prepped for that
yeah what else I mean it's nice classic
we talked about it a lot but yeah Super
Metroid I'm pumped play Secret of Mana
Link to the Past Mega Man X almost every
game on the Super Nintendo classic is
really good - Chrono Trigger of course
yeah
any final Metroid Samus Returns flouts I
selfishly please buy this game because I
want more yeah so more of these I look
forward to playing it i guess i will
also say there's some amiibo stuff the
fusion suit is locked to amiibo you can
use it after beating the game you do
unlock a hard mode after beating the
game anyway so there's still a more
challenging difficult and I haven't seen
the fusion suit actually lead to any
different capabilities I think it might
just be a reat anchoring of the
difficulty and Cosmetics it is too bad
it's stuck to the amiibo because it's on
the cart Xie me bow is so cute see me
more great as toys yeah the content
locked to them is maybe a little
troublesome no I agree it's squishy it's
squishy yeah it's like hollow yeah
probably be able to talk about next week
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite yeah if you
always been playing it we can't talk
about it yet was the 19 they're
streaming tomorrow before the giveaway
like I said we stream pretty much every
day at 11:00 Pacific 11:00 a.m. Pacific
so tomorrow I guess Eric K and Joey I'm
assuming you're gonna be playing Marvel
vs. Capcom infinite I always get those
like subtitles mixed up but then we'll
also have a lot of Destiny stuff coming
out hopefully the raid goes well when
they start in about an hour and then
we'll keep you all updated on that oh
and the Nintendo Direct is today oh yeah
what time is that at 3 o'clock Nintendo
Direct is at 3 o'clock oh yeah actually
we have like specifically do we have
predictions we know we're gonna see is
there like a general there's gonna be
some Mario Odyssey stuff I think they're
probably going to announce not as you
switch bundle I think now is the right
time for them to announce that for the
holidays I'm hoping another like like
Wii U port announcement
that'd be cool they don't smash there'd
be a pretty big deal maybe Bank yeah I
think within a way that like a new
character or a few will be good Metroid
just a guardian from Brazil awhile just
reckon everyone and that oh my god
imagine like um what are their name like
me feh and Ravalli volley would be a
dope character so you could just do his
voice oh man
Rob you want to pipe in don't you
Valley's gonna vomit one more random
thought
Nintendo updated the the switch app so
you no longer have to keep your phone
unlocked to chat with your friends you
can let your phone sleep don't know how
that was an oversight to begin with but
okay sweet
Nintendo's fixing a lot of its mistakes
let's just hope it's not doing well yeah
yeah totally it continues into next year
which Ness classic and NES coming back
are a good start cool that was my show
kind of giveaway this is actually cool
because it was originally just North
America but we have PES 2018 and a PES
fidgets spin-off you just spin URLs or
this is good for ps4 this is good in the
UK and US feel like it's got a big
audience in the UK we are going to be
tweeting that out right now pretty much
Shiva who does our manage our Twitter
account will be tween that out from the
GameSpot account if you don't follow us
go do so and retweet that and we will
pick the winners Saturday and spin
visitors so happy I didn't tell me about
this before we came in here that's
hilarious
why how did those things happen that's a
whole lady hurry the lady who started
them didn't patent them so like
everybody made money off them but it was
just originally someone who is
originally for like ADHD yeah totally
yeah and initially it was like a cube
that had a bunch of weird all the fidget
cubes are cool II don't like press all
the buttons my dad actually sent me one
of those cuz he was he's like 70 and he
was diagnosed with ADHD just last year
really and it explains so many things I
can't imagine what what you have done
Rob imagine being an a middle school
teacher my friends a teacher and she's
she's subbing right now and the teacher
had a tech tech on their desk and I was
like she's just on our way into class or
by god when they tried to do the razor
scooter once I just ended up taping it
to my fingers I could do sick tricks
yeah I think what once the once they did
the Razor scooter it was like okay we're
done so if you want the fidgets spinner
and PES 2018 which is out as of
yesterday you can go to GameSpot or our
Twitter account and check out the link
and we'll pick winners for in the UK or
us on Saturday
thank you yeah there's been a show good
start I just had to shart
all right we'll be back next week as
always Wednesday at 11:00 a.m. Pacific I
might not be here I don't know yet might
be doing a video shoot somewhere should
be a pretty cool project but it's kind
of becoming a last-minute thing
well I'm not gonna be here so I ain't
hosting Tokyo Tokyo Tokyo Game Show
Tokyo Game Show Tokyo Game Show are you
excited so I think I said sharp
no I'm I'm excited I feel like
incredibly guilty so I will not have any
fun oh no it'll be it'll be good it's
not really clear like what the big thing
is gonna be at the show so we have our
work cut out for us to identify that
mm-hmm you get to uh can you talk about
any like studios you're visiting or
people you're gonna talk to while you're
there um we'll be talking to Shinji
Mikami
we'll be talking to start hallo rub I
should be interviewing the head of Sonic
Team easy cuz that's awesome can you
bring back green tea Kit Kats that's the
easiest of the kid cast to attain yes oh
can you bring back a kick ass you can
just buy those at your pan town yeah
I'll get them at the airport right well
you'll be in Tokyo I might be out of
town so just let you two figure out the
show he interrupts be like so
hello yeah yeah hey loan the switch
alright everybody thank you for joining
whether it's on YouTube or twitch or
GameSpot we love having you as always
get your questions in yeah you shut that
for me and we'll be back next week or
some of us will at least 11:00 a.m.
Pacific thanks for joining we'll see you
then
[Music]